we could all use a little help sometimes
but asking for it often makes us feel so
uncomfortable research shows that people
underestimate the odds of getting
assistance when they asked for it by
nearly 50% social psychologist Heidi
grant is the author of the recently
published book reinforcements how to get
people to help you she says were
actually wired to be helpful but have to
learn the best ways to ask Heidi grant
good morning and welcome to the team
you know what I learned after reading
your book that I'm doing everything
wrong started with I always feel that
I'm it's a burden to ask me to do
something so I hate asking number one
and number two I never ask in person I
like an email or a tax or a by-the-by
you said that's wrong yeah you're kind
of doing everything wrong the truth is
that it's you know yes there's an extent
to which when we ask someone for their
help we're asking them to put an effort
we're asking them to take time but for
the most part we're really
overestimating that we're focusing only
on that and not thinking about how
rewarding it is actually be helpful
there's tons of research that shows
there's basically nothing human beings
do that's more rewarding and gives them
a bigger boost of self esteem than being
helpful so people actually like helping
they get a warm glow they get a kick out
of it when I feel you're putting people
on the spot I mean to some extent you
are there is a discomfort when people
have to say no and that is actually part
of the reason why asking over email or
text is a bad idea because they're not
as on the spot you know it's easier for
you to ask by email because you feel
more comfortable it's easier for them to
say no yeah they feel more comfortable
so important pick up the phone pick up
the phone in fact you've got data that
shows a person is 34 times more
effective when they ask in person yeah
in person or by phone it's that live
interaction 34 times more likely to get
a yes and and we do this all the time
people ask by email they'll do the even
worse thing which is send a group email
so send an email to 20 people asking if
one of them can help and everyone just
ignores the Commons Heidi let me ask you
this somebody once said you can separate
the world into two people the people who
ask and don't mind if you tell them no
and then people say oh no they're not
gonna do I'm not gonna ask and then you
shrink off what distinguishes a person
if they're in one camp or another I mean
there's certain traits that you have
that put you in
I don't think it's so much I think it's
a little bit life experience and those
people who ask have just sort of caught
on to the fact that it's very difficult
to be successful in life without asking
for a lot of help and so they kind of
just built that muscle of getting past
the discomfort you know we talk a lot
about how important it is to have a
network rate of allies and people spend
a lot of time building that network to
be successful but then they don't know
how to tap into the network by asking
those people to actually help them and
you said don't assume people are mind
reader's you haven't let people know
that you need help yeah including your
spouse and everyone else the truth is
our art our need for help is far less
obvious than we believe it is it's
obvious to us it's not obvious to anyone
else you have to explicitly ask and you
say be specific about what your ask is I
can sometimes get an email and I'm like
well what is it that they want what is
the worst when someone sends you an
email they say you know I'd love to just
get together and chat catch up or catch
up and it's like well no you want some
so I can tell you I'd like to banish the
phrase pick your brain all right how
about the other how about the other end
of the telescope so when you're a person
should you make yourself available to
help other people in other words lower
it help lower the barrier for other
people so that they might just being a
friend I think that's a really useful
thing to do because we do have to
recognize people will find it
uncomfortable to ask so if you invite
that it's going to be easier there is
research that shows that you want to be
careful though because being a giver is
a great thing to a point but some givers
can experience a lot of burnout when
they give too much and they don't focus
enough on themselves so you want to
always strike that balance between
giving as much as you can but making
sure you're still taking care of you so
your best way to ask for help without
being a burden to people is what well to
be as explicit as possible to say this
is exactly what I need and exactly how I
need it and then they can feel confident
that they can make a decision about
whether or not they can help you
everyone wants to be an effective helper
yeah one wants to be a bad helper so the
more clear you are the better aren't you
I need Heidi to be an effective helper
and help us get out here
yeah thank you you're welcome
reinforcement is on sale now you are
watching CBS this morning thanks for
your help we'll be right back
you